toute blanche maison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison alors que l'europe on
disait un ceux des confine kelly
précisément la situation sanitaire en
inde qui dorment suscite beaucoup
d'inquiétude apparemment on a de la
vague pandémique en fête a été plus
tardive qu en europe et est qu'en
amérique
elle a été également d'une amplitude du
fait qu en europe qu'en amérique alors
on prévoit son pic en effet un deuxième
quinzaine de juillet comme s'était dit
dans votre votre sujet et cela a permis
à au premier ministre une arène rabaudy
de souligner que le virus avait moindre
emprise sur les indiens que sur les
européens ou que sur les américains mais
depuis le déconfinement après deux mois
de confinement et bien on apprend on
voit une résurgence en effet dans un
certain nombre de grandes villes bombay
delhi
et puis madras chennai puisque le
gouvernement du tamil nadu a décidé
lundi de reconfirmer chennai 15 millions
de personnes à partir de vendredi
prochain pour une période d'environ
d'environ deux semaines
alors évidemment ceci fait apparaître
que monsieur n'arrête un body a
probablement sous-estimé la pandémie
dans avec à huningue qui évidemment un
appareil de santé qui est notoirement
sous développés puisque en gros il y a
sept lits pour dix mille habitants en
inde et un médecin de médecine générale
pour 10000 habitants aussi ce qui est en
effet très peu dans que le système de
santé est débordé des hôpitaux publics
sous équipés sont débordés et quant aux
hôpitaux et aux cliniques privées et
évidemment ils sont très chers et
totalement inaccessible pour une bonne
partie de la population
alors voilà quelle est la situation
aujourd'hui et cela dit jusqu'à présent
si l'on rapporte le nombre de personnes
infectées et le nombre de morts à la
population indienne un milliard trois
cent cinquante millions évidemment le
taux est très très inférieur à ce qu'on
a pu constater jusqu'à présent en europe
et en amérique alors l'une des
conséquences 1 2
cette pandémie ce sont les migrations
internes pouvez vous expliquer ce
phénomène
le 24 mars
narendra modi le premier ministre a
décidé brutalement de mettre tout plein
dans situation de confinement est en
effet tous les travailleurs migrants
précaire il y en a environ 100 millions
en inde et bien se sont trouvés sans
salaire se sont trouvés sans emploi est
éloigné de parfois de plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres de leur village
d'origine
il n'y a pas de sécurité sociale en inde
et par conséquent il n'avait pas
beaucoup d'autres choix que de chercher
par tous moyens à rejoindre leur village
d'origine où se trouvent leurs familles
leurs amis
malheureusement tous les transports
avait été arrêté dans le confinement et
beaucoup d'entre eux n'ont pas pu
rejoindre ces villages sont partis à
pied certains sont morts
des phénomènes de également de de famine
se sont développées et c'est une
véritable situation de désastre
humanitaire qui a eu lieu en ahl à ce
moment là alors aujourd'hui la plupart
de ces travailleurs migrants qui sont
retour pur tourné finalement chez eux
c'est-à-dire dans les pays l'est dans
les états les plus pauvres de l'inde et
la plupart d'entre eux ne sont pas
encore revenus dans les états où il yal
où il était employé et par conséquent un
certain nombre d'usinés redémarrer mais
sont à court de madoff ce qui retarde le
déconfinement et de redémarrage
économique de l'inde qui est le souci
majeur maintenant deux du gouvernement
indien quelles conséquences précisément
économique pour le pays
alors on pense généralement que le pays
cette année fera -3% de pnb alors que
l'année dernière il avait des plus 4,5
pour cent ce qui n'est pas mal comparé à
des pays d'europe occidentale mais ce
qui est peu pour l'inde puisque chaque
année l'un d'eux doit accueillir sur
marché de l'emploi
environ 10 millions de jeunes que pour
accueillir 10 millions de jeunes il faut
un taux de croissance d'au moins 8% par
an donc c'est tout à fait dramatique et
il va y avoir un choc social important
avec déjà d'ores et déjà un quart de la
population au chômage et à une
augmentation de la proportion de la
population qui se trouve dans une
situation de pauvreté absolue
la banque mondiale indique que la
pauvreté absolue c'est en dessous de 1,9
dollar par jour eh bien il ya à peu près
3 400 millions d'indiens qui se trouvent
vont se trouver dans cette situation
par ailleurs évidemment l'économie est
en train est en train de reprendre avec
les difficultés que je viens de dire
pour pour ce qui est des laits des
travailleurs pour ce qui est de la main
d'oeuvre alors locaux vides 19 est ce
qu'on peut dire qu'il remet en cause la
place de l'inde sur l'échiquier mondial
écoutez moi je le crois pas je ne le
crois pas parce que l'inde reste a
marché avec un potentiel très important
d'ailleurs on a constaté pendant même
les semaines qui viennent de s'écouler
pendant la pandémie que volks wagen
avait décidé d'investir des sommes
considérables pour conquérir le marché
indien puisque évidemment le marché de
l'automobile en inde est à et à
développer et c'est le cas dans beaucoup
d'eau dans beaucoup d'autres secteurs
un exemple parmi d'autres mais on
pourrait en prendre beaucoup d'eau par
ailleurs c'est un marché avec une main
d'oeuvre abondante en partie bien formés
et par conséquent il peut attirer les
investissements étrangers
d'ailleurs
moody a mis sur la table un plan de
relance économique de 260 milliards de
dollars pour la plupart orientée vers
les entreprises et pour la plupart
orienté également vers un
assouplissement du code du travail pour
rendre l'un des plus attractives à un
moment où la chine l'est peut-être moins
pour des raisons notamment politiques et
puis par ailleurs là d'un atout
fantastique c'est qu'elle est
nécessairement le contrepoids à une
chine qui devient un petit peu
envahissante à la fois en asie où elle
domine tout le commerce mais aussi dans
le monde on le voit bien avec les
réactions américaine actuelle est donc
l'un d'eux joue de cette carte elle est
le contrepoids le contrepoids naturel à
l'influencent de la chine
d'ailleurs
monsieur trucks ne s'y est pas trompé
puisque au début de l'année au mois de
février juste avant le développement de
l'épidémie et s'est rendu en visite
officielle en inde et que il a traité
essayé beaucoup de d'accord avec
monsieur maudit il avait d'ailleurs
accueilli en 2010 est à washington et en
2019 à houston où il avait rencontré
avec lui toute la communauté des indiens
qui sont des résidents américains et qui
sont quand vous savez très nombreux et
qui joue un rôle également dans les
relations entre les deux pays
alors peut-être que c'est l'une des
raisons qui pourraient expliquer la
tension actuelle le regain de tension
actuelle dans lés malaya puisque ces
jours ci il ya eu des morts les indiens
ont annoncé qu'ils avaient eu 20 morts
parmi leurs soldats et en effet
probablement que sur ces zones où la
frontière des mal déterminées s'agit
d'ailleurs pas d'une frontière
il s'agit d'une zone où il ya une ligne
de démarcation ligne de cessez-le-feu et
les chinois se sont rappelés au bon
souvenir des indiens en construisant des
routes qui jouxte cette ligne cessez le
feu et les indiens sont en train de
prendre des décisions du même genre
alors avec directive mans des risques de
frictions et de frottement militaire
mais il n'y aura pas de guerre entre la
chine et l'inde
tout simplement parce que ces deux pays
ont l'armé atomique merci claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales